i think maybe mr beast because he has a
community
may not go to paramount pictures to make
the mr beast movie or maybe even not
even netflix
youtuber mr beast spends four million
dollars a month to make what three or
four youtube videos what do you think
about that
well i think if the market
watches it and it works for him i think
that's great i mean i think you know if
his if he gets a return on his
investment if we get if the roi makes
sense
mazel tov i think that's amazing uh and
i am presuming that you know if you look
at his numbers and the subscribers uh it
seems like the market is bearing out his
approach and um so so i think it's great
i mean you know again with with any with
any budget right i mean uh with with you
know game of thrones spending 10 million
dollars for one episode of tv for the
lord of the rings series spending you
know 20 million dollars for one episode
of television or him spending four
million dollars for youtube video
if if if that
if that creates a positive roi and
creates something that people enjoy and
the audience responds to i think it's
awesome i think it's awesome i don't
think it's it's a necessity for
everybody i think uh uh
the trap is to think
is well that means i have to spend four
million dollars on the up on an episode
or or on a youtube video or if i don't
spend uh four million dollars then i
can't do a good youtube series or i
think people get in their head about
that stuff and try to create rules and
things like that uh but his brand is
built around these super complicated
expensive
stunts and
crazy things that he does and uh and i
think you know that's that works for him
and obviously he gets results from that
and so
you know i don't want to criticize that
i think it's great and it's working you
know but but at the same time i think
other people
may can do a very successful youtube
series for zero dollars uh i don't think
it sets a sets a bright line rule for
everybody to follow but for him he's
making it work for sure
have you studied mr beast at all have
you sort of done a deep dive with some
of his videos sure yeah i've i've i i
don't i don't i wouldn't say i'm a fan
i'm not one of his fans that that
subscribe to his channel and watch all
his stuff uh but definitely aware of all
the different things that he has done
and how he's grown his brand and
diversified his brand in a really
interesting way and the philanthropy
he's he's done he does a lot of really
cool uh philanthropic uh initiatives so
uh so definitely aware and appreciative
of of his approach for sure what do you
think other creators can learn from his
success i think what creators can learn
from the success of mr beast is
use the platform that you have in front
of you use the platform that is there
and for free that you don't have to uh
you know wait for cbs to give you a tv
deal to be able to uh to start building
your audience and this is a refrain that
i always go back to is use the tools
that you have attack the market with
what you have and and if then if your
stuff is good enough uh then you're
gonna start building building that
audience out and so that's what i love
about mr beast is is he just used what
was in front of him whether it's youtube
whether it's twitch whether it's tick
tock whatever it is use the tools that
you have also uh you look at volume i
think you know mr beast uh you know he
he produces a lot of content uh and uh
it's not just
one thing every now and then like it's
it's you know his big stunt prank things
uh uh you know are windowed but there's
a lot of content that comes through the
variety of his channels because he
doesn't just have one channel he has
multiple channels right and so basically
he's his own network if you look at it
in the traditional sense and so volume
of content in a commoditized market is a
strategy that's super super important if
you only do one thing every now and then
in a commoditized market there's so much
new content that hits the market your
one thing just disappears because
there's too much stuff that that sort of
buries it right so you have to be able
to
take a volume based strategy to be able
to compete in in a commoditized market
and that's what mr beast is doing lots
of content on the platforms that are
that are available to him that the
platforms that that he's on and what i
like about him is is is diversification
is is he has different channels and
different types of things he tries
different formats uh it's not just a
one-trick pony it's he's willing to try
new and different things
on different platforms in different
styles and different formats and genres
and and and really diversify the brand
and if you look at
if you listen if you read warren buffett
and listen to warren buffett which i
don't know if mr b's listen to warren
buffett or not but
warren buffett says
he never
he never suggests that investors
invest into companies that that operate
and commoditize markets because it's
just too this is just too difficult for
them to compete unless they have the
right strategy of competing in the
commoditized market which he says is
creating a branded ecosystem based on
diversification diversification and
volume and synergy is your stuff tied
together are you creating lots of stuff
and are you diversifying the type of
stuff that you're creating and the
platforms that you're creating on and if
you look at what mr beast is doing he's
really doing a great job of the synergy
of volume and diversification and so i
think that's why he's able to to to
compete in the commodities market which
is that's the big takeaway that as a
filmmaker for me is that's what i
learned from from him he's not waiting
on anybody to give him permission to
create his stuff
and now that he's created it himself on
this platform guess what he owns the
brand nobody owns that else owns his
brand and if if cbs or abc or amazon or
netflix or whoever decides to come and
say hey we want to do a whole you know
mr beast movie or a mr beast cartoon or
a mr beast uh series
he's now in a leveraged position to
where he will decide
uh uh
how
how that deal will play out uh because
he owns his own brand look what happened
with with joe rogan and spotify uh you
know like he did a 500 million dollar
deal with spotify for his podcast
because he owned his podcast because he
launched his podcast before he got
getting involved with spotify and grew
his own audience and that's that's what
i love about mr beast is mr beast owns
this brand it's his
he doesn't have any any uh uh
you know of these of these studios or
networks uh uh divvying up the rights or
or controlling him or dictating the
content like he's in the driver's seat
of his brand which as a creator i
i'm always going to uh root for and i'm
impressed by and um and so that i'm a
fan of that um and that's why i think
filmmakers can learn from him as well is
own your brand use the tools that you
have in front of you diversify and and
attack the market with volume he's doing
all those things and and and it's
working for him it's playing out in the
market
what do you think about mr b's
purchasing 100 acres of land and
building a 10 million dollar studio it's
23. i think it's i think it's amazing i
mean i think if you look at if you look
at
what tyler perry did if you look at what
robert rodriguez's of what he did mean
he's following in those footsteps as a
youtuber which is amazing and it the
more you could
disintermediate
other people that control your stuff and
control your content or control the way
you produce the content
or or how you produce the content when
you produce the content where you
produce content the more that you can
just own
your own brand in every way that's
always going to be better right and and
you know it's it's an asset i mean it's
it's you know he's now
a real estate
magnet right like it's it's uh the fact
that i mean that gives that's that's
valuable that's financially valuable but
the fact that he's creating his own
studios is it just shows
nobody's going to tell him how to create
window create and why to create
so if you're using youtube studios
there's strings attached if you use
as well there should be because they're
they're it's youtube studios right if
somebody's coming to my studio or your
studio of course there's you know you're
going to tell me how i should act i
should tell you how you should act and
how you there's always going to be
strings attached and which means
ultimately you don't really own your
stuff yeah you know i mean it's like
it's like moving into a neighborhood
with a with with with a really
aggressive hoa right the fact that you
know if you can't let your lawn grow
more than six inches high else you start
getting fines do you really own your
lawn at that point uh i mean there's
like an interesting like for me i don't
like that i don't like people telling me
how like when i need to cut my grass or
i can't how quickly i need to remove my
trash cans from the curb before i get
the ticket i don't like that right i
feel like there's my trash cans this is
my lawn i should be able to do with what
i want right i feel like that's the
american way and that's and and so i
love the fact that
an independent creator doesn't have to
go to some giant conglomerate
to be able to make the stuff and this is
a refrain that i always go back to yeah
is is how does the how does the
filmmaker
not wait for permission from a giant
multi-billion dollar international
conglomerate uh
to to say you can
you can create the stuff that's in your
heart how do you just go ahead and do it
yourself and by creating his own
production facilities just like tyler
perry just like robert rodriguez just
like you know im not shyamalan just just
like any of these independent creators
that go and do their own thing he he's
doing that and he's gonna he's gonna
have his destiny in his own hands
that doesn't preclude him from working
with any of these other people but it
just puts him in more of a leveraged
position because he just has more
ownership over everything literally has
more ownership over the whole thing
we think it's only a matter of time
before mr beast will make
a movie and it'll gross 100 million
dollars plus
what do you think about that oh yeah i'm
certain of it i think uh
he will be able to continue to grow the
brand to the point where if there's
demand
for a feature film or or for something
uh like that or even a tv series of
course i mean you look at something
another youtube breakout uh the hot ones
which was an interview show on youtube
that was wildly popular and it was a
very basic concept where this guy he
interviews a famous person and
they eat hot wings as they as they as
they interview and the hot wings get
hotter as they go right super clever
concept right that just you know that
slowly built a very massive audience
that 100 million people subscribe to the
channel and eventually then he gets his
own
real uh reality show and own real uh on
actual tv he now has an interview show
and he gets called up to the major
leagues because that's usually the way
it goes uh but he estab but he owns the
brand he established it first so that
typically is is the
the the path that that that uh brands go
in now does that
does that necessarily mean that he'll
have to do it no i think you know he
you know i obviously
i don't think he would need to do it for
any financial benefit necessarily i
don't think at this point he's super
motivated by money because he's been
very financially successful which i
think is a good thing so i think
mr beast will look at look at the
options of i don't have to do it for
money so the reasons i'll do it is
it are the reasons that will help grow
the brand feed the fan base in the right
organic way that makes sense for the
brand uh where people i think where
where brands get off is is it off track
is when they
do it for a money grab
and it it's not coherent to the brand
and it doesn't feel like it's contextual
in in in in a in a way that
that adds value to the fan base it just
feels like a
sellout payday right and sometimes it
can feel like that uh but i think with
mr beast taken ownership the brand
in the way that he's done and been able
to amass
the serious wealth that he's been able
to amass with the brand that the
motivation won't be money it'll be
something else and it doesn't mean it's
going to be great this doesn't mean it's
going to work but i do think
he'll probably follow that path
you look at something you know a board
game um
that was that was created called throw
throw burrito uh is uh and exploding
kittens and there was there's there's
something uh that that created these
indie board games on kickstarter and um
and they got to be super popular and um
now they're being turned into cartoons
and you know and and tv shows and movies
and things like that because that's the
way the entertainment industry works
right is eventually you get you get that
big break for the big platforms i think
mr beast
will
will do something non-traditional i
think maybe mr beast because he has a
community
may not go to paramount pictures to make
the mr beast movie or maybe even not
even netflix i think maybe mr beast does
something very non-traditional like like
launching a movie as an nft
on the blockchain uh and um uh pulling
the community in participation of of uh
of the movie through the nft so they
could actually now participate as as
equity partners
in the exploitation of the film and and
try something different because there's
no downside for him to try that uh and
there's no reason he has to go to
traditional hollywood i think you know
just the fact that he's been so new
media with everything and so outside the
quote-unquote system of hollywood
i i i would guess
that before he would go to a universal
pictures or or
or paramount pictures or disney or
something like that or nickelodeon i
think it would be
i think you would explore something
non-traditional like launching it on the
blockchain which i think would be great
because the thing that makes nfts work
is community having an established
community that can jump in and purchase
the nft purchase the tokens that then
monetizes
the uh
the product the movie or whatever it is
monetizes the whole project um and then
gives them that profit participation and
a stake in the actual brand that where
nfts fail is a lack of community is is
they launched nft and there's nobody
nobody there to buy them because they
haven't built community first the nfts
that are really working are the ones
that have community first then launch
the nft uh and so
the fact that mr beast has amassed so
many subscribers amass this huge
community i would i would be shocked if
if if he didn't explore something like
an nft to be able to launch a series or
launch a movie and you're already seeing
craters kind of moving into that so it's
not completely like untested waters
but
i would i would guess that there would
be some sort of
willingness to do something
non-traditional outside the system as a
way to create that movie or create that
tv show